nobody is smart enough or strong enough
to do this thing called leadership all
by themselves leadership is just too
difficult the great leaders I know they
know how to ask for help they know how
to say I don't understand I think number
one is there's no such thing as a great
leader without a a team of great people
around them leadership is a team sport
and thinking you have to do everything
alone you're going to burn yourself out
and you're going to break yourself and
ultimately you'll hurt the organization
so ask for help when you need it admit
you don't know things when you don't
know them and you find your surr
surrounded by people who want to help
you